previously on the forest we should go to
a cave
but where are them oh found it god here
mark you find it yeah i did
oh he has arms no there are no arms on
this dude no no the one orphan
oh that dude all right actually this is
perfect this is perfect this part
yeah oh damn we got tnt dynamite
i got something better wait wait we got
molotov watch out bob i'm gonna throw
another
yeah yeah got him
oh they're all dead can we get
through this
oh yeah oh yeah secret
oh god
holy crap i want to close the doors i
would like to close the doors
oh my god
okay he's like stuck over there we go
back that was a horrible surprise
that might have been that's like one of
the scariest things that has
ever happened to me in all my years of
playing horror games i need to build a
fire
i'm gonna die holy hey mark i'm
going to sit with you by your
campfire yeah come on wow dude look at
this
god in heaven we missed a katana
says chad we missed a katana well that
sounds pretty cool should we go back and
get it yeah they go
dude we need to get the katada right
was it down the path that i was going it
might be this one
is this where you were yeah there's also
the path way back when
well yeah we'll get to it i'm not in too
big of a hurry to go to where we were
just going if i'm honest
yeah you know i'm not super concerned
about that path well wait it'll have it
all sorted by the time we get done who
pitches
ah pictures hey dynamite oh yes
hey pictures and dynamite hey guys uh
there's uh it's a tight squeeze over
here
oh yeah i can find it yeah
i'm coming okay there's a more dynamite
that's good
yes okay more dynamite that's always
good this says high explosive i just
tried to chop the high explosive bags
oh oh bob what
but don't run out as fast as you can is
this a cave you came out of before us is
a different one
no this is different i was lower down oh
wow what is it at the bottom there's a
little
it's like a corpse of some kind is that
what the helicopter is that a helicopter
oh my god it's so far down is that like
there's like a sideways destroyed
helicopter oh yeah i didn't
recognize what it was
okay well i don't want to be on that
ledge oh wait i'm like full of dynamite
yeah over here but i'm gonna go chuck a
dynamite at the dude
i'm gonna run backwards to the other
path that i saw and see if i find the
katana that way yeah i'll keep working
on the dude you guys go look for those
um and then we'll meet back up whoever
has the most valuable thing
if i light this and uh it uh it goes off
in my hand what does that do for me
probably not great probably my degrees
painful death
oh where are you at buddy oh where is he
oh god where is he maybe he's dead so i
got a good
pops over here
i hear some gurglies
oh there it is oh my god what are you
doing buddy
oh i don't like it laughs oh
wow can it not go past this point for
some
reason oh god oh my god
oh my god oh nice ass
i hope it doesn't move it's moving
all right mark i'm good don't worry
about me don't die
i would never we're in this together
wade
this thing is really tough
all right there's no katana i've been
betrayed and lied to
oh go inside the kingdom wait get inside
oh you oh you guys okay
what are you guys looking at and what
are you dealing with we found a way out
but there was people waiting for us and
they're
naked okay
how far do i have to go people were
saying now it may be where we entered i
don't know man i feel lied too
i've thrown four pieces of dynamite this
thing and it has yet to die
these things are tough my
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
where does it stop
oh god we're just in no no no
oh it blew oh
i did it oh gross
oh my god when it finally goes it goes
oh
god oh dude i'm rich
okay i've never seen this much money in
my life
okay oh god oh god
i'm not seeing anything in this area i
found the sword oh my god you found a
sword that's great
where am i going
oh god oh
god god i did not oh
god oh god oh my god
yeah i know mark it's so exciting
oh yeah i'm coming for the sword just
save one for me okay save one for me
mark you definitely gotta get over here
where are you
which way did you go all the way to the
entrance basically where we fought the
first
monster there's hairspray you can use
with a lighter
mark there's so much stuff i'm on the
way i ended up killing the big guy but
there are
more um not big guys but there's more
guys oh no bob there's another
there's another chainsaw wall over here
oh i'm here
i'm with it am i going the right way how
far back was this so like right here
is where you go okay oh we were right
next to it
there's so much look at my sword mark
that's a nice sword man
you're about to be your mind is about to
wrinkle your brain is about to
absolutely
implode on itself with the riches that
await you okay all right okay
okay check out this box nice whoa
right right right this is dope as hell
oh katana yeah
damn this is dope uh there's meds
there's food and trees there's water
like there's
so many water need here wow
if you get a little rolex dude this is
sick
there's a flashlight flashlight the
flashlight oh
like you plastic torch oh
hello heads so it does how do i use that
you have to go into your thing and equip
it it just turns on there's so much
random
on the left side it's on the left side
over here
oh it's got a battery oh my god oh
that's just
way better yeah where's the battery if
you hover over it in your
inventory it'll say uh i'll switch off
of it for now then save it for later
yeah i'll uh
i'll switch back to the lighter oh no
yeah if you equip that it just gets that
out automatically
let's see go ahead and equip the lighter
shall we oh yeah i gotta switch to the
lighter
oh does the katana craft into something
what would you poison the weapon you put
cloth on it and turn it into one you can
make it be
poison oh my god wait i'm gonna tr i'm
gonna
make a fiery katana oh you can't you
lied to me
you lied you'd think it would be
possible though
one more twin berry i could have
poisoned katana
that's great man all right fyi people
over here they may have gone back up but
the further you go here the more people
you will find we got this
katanas out baby between katanas and
chainsaw we can't lose
it's pretty okay i see a dude he's about
to get cut
wham oh god is it a one shot one kill
it is not uh many hits
many hits ah many hits really smacking
you up there mark
you think this is yeah well
all right maybe i should learn how to
block
oh my god stuff comes out right hanging
corpses the block
what does it oh my god oh my god it's
just
half holy crap yeah well it got katana
in half
oh money falls out guys they're
corpseatas
happy birthday so which way are we going
mark's
other way up here there's more up here
but i think it's just a way out but i
just wanted to make sure
are some there's a rope down there's a
climbing rope to go down down here
well there's this is just yeah
yeah big dude oh why me
learn to block two of them
taking the left one he's pinned oh yeah
he's unlocked yeah i think the thing
about the katana is it takes like no
stamina so you can just
keep stunning them you guys are just
bouncing them back and forth
oh and oh oh is he dead hey guys you can
chop bits off
really really dissected them i just want
to remove the head so they don't get
back up from their magical
shaman i removed all the limbs so that's
probably pretty effective
yeah i uh i chopped a head off so i
think i'm good
i think i'm a good person they don't
have any legs they can't really do
anything to us you know oh wow
guys come over here it's a real corpse
pinata party
look at the corpse yeah outs
this doesn't feel right guys this feels
a lot of money guys this one's paying
out
look at those ropes and gasoline
someone said we could burn these bodies
too and get
both bones oh oh here's a picture in
here
something i can't pick it up can you
pick that up
no no no bob please don't wedge me in
here bob please
oh my god wait come in here wait come
into the tent quickly
okay damn it i was trying okay where did
you say you went that went oh right here
oh over here right oh
oh down i'm down today
baby guys come in here
all right right crack i am
uh
okay nothing under the waterfall no
secrets
no that's pretty disappointing honestly
um there's a waterfall should always
have secret layers behind them
that's what i'm saying yeah every
waterfall in every
waterfall exists in a game without
having a secret behind it it's always so
disappointing when there isn't
i know oh hey
oh we're me huh it's my turn huh
that's right get it get it no
each other uh i don't know i
don't think so don't worry guys i got
this actually from what i remember
about friendly fire i think maybe yes we
absolutely can
okay didn't i kill you with the chainsaw
i'm sure it happened
i hear grumping oh yeah another one guys
where over here oh he's coming
he's scampering he's scampering
hey that wasn't my best move
so what's the big thing we're looking
for in this cave the map
uh yeah map something else i know it's
not just the cantana
there was another path remember wait a
while back you were like
oh do you go left or right and then you
went down my way that i went
bob you went down that way already
didn't you no i'm
the way bob went not the bat way but
there was another way
bob did did that lead to a dead end or
yeah it dead ended
okay well then i don't know well there's
the rope up that we thought was the way
out here maybe that leads
further no that'd probably be an exit
i mean this might just be the end of it
we've explored a fair amount could be
let me
let me double check let me double check
because i think there was a there was a
list of what was in
the caves too oh katana flashlight
that's the only thing's in this cave
okay we're good
where am i oh god please don't leave me
behind
bye mark my dude obama
guys my guys boys boys don't leave me
boys
climbing up the rope leaving mark behind
actually it's okay bob you have to deal
with that then i'm pretty sure i'm okay
you can hear it just as much as i can
it's not like you're further away from
no no it's all echoey and distant for me
it's it's it's
very uh very very
[Music]
honestly it's pretty beautiful i'm super
into that yeah okay i think though if we
go in cave number two
that's the one that's going to have the
map
and the other things you know mark i
think you should navigate us to that
all right you guys oh son of a oh
where are we
mark hey wait where are you behind where
are you
oh i was exploring the little village
friends friends
you guys want to help yeah one of them
throwing fire rocks at me
oh god all right time i'm dying
oh not today not today not today i'm
dead bye
no no oh you're on fire oh my god how do
i pick you up
i'm all the way dead yeah there you go
oh thanks
spreading a while away from the bad guys
all right
being on fire seems to seems to do a
number on you
so i need some meat to eat
i might have a body right here you can
grab a leg no no
it's pretty good well i'm going to head
back get some
oh yeah yeah more over here i'm coming
i'm coming
let's get him man let's get him getting
three more three more there's a lot more
there seems to be
an ever increasing number stop attacking
our bob yeah will not divide
us oh he didn't attack me he's coming
for you no one's leaving
that's right you better run tell them
he's bringing
out with his
i loved him in the beginning of
prometheus
i killed him super fast he might be
getting better
stronger faster that's right you better
run if we ever come back
we'll kill you
okay i'm gonna go home yeah and
get some meat yeah let's restock
reconfigure the plan and then build
another bridge
and then move on to the okay i found a
douche bag over here
oh you guys got it yeah i believe in you
this one has a helmet of some kind
helmet
why did i do this cloth wrapped around
their face for some reason
for flammability what
what what hello i
don't know
you find something work are you just
responding
hey we're communicating i'm starting to
learn these people
guys are you having fun i thought we
were going home
guys we're just massacring this entire
population
sweet shot oh god it ducked right what a
god damn you oh
it went so far oh god
maybe you shouldn't throw yours oh
my god maybe the lesson to be alone
is obvious and you should have grounded
it
look how far my spear was i'm i'm
standing where i
picked it up uh it just couldn't have
been more perfect
wait wait wait i'm gonna get it watch
this god
i hate spears they make no sense
they're
your spear is so big oh my god big
lovely
spear how many viewers out there would
love to be impaled by mark spear let us
know
there got it jesus pop up hills
i'm feeling good
are you high on the drug dude i am
higher than a butterfly on the 4th of
july
why did it run away you will not run
i'm going to kill anything mark where's
the next cave
i wasn't paying attention
during cave school hey mark how you
doing
i'm fine i will get this deer and we
will eat vivaciously
it's getting very far away mark tonight
well it's good because i throw it
very far oh it's a really absolute
unit of a spear truck that works it
disappeared
it's gone your spirit disappeared no
the deer oh just
i just got a squirrel mark we could eat
some squirrel
i killed a rabbit good work buddy
thank you first try deer
ah damn it guys i'm apparently carrying
a human head
you're dead now i did it i did it guys i
killed that deer
dead i am starting to never mind i'm
sure i just landed that spear in the
base that was a good throw
cooking human head he's good
he's good he's eating ahead fix the
skateboard the way no one gets that
reference everyone gets it because i
make it every
day i you know i get that reference i
appreciate that
i don't get it why can't i eat this head
i can't do it i can't do it what would
you
eat what would you eat of a head look i
don't know the
oh god oh no god oh god i ate the head
oh god
oh what would you eat of a head did i
eat the head
what part of the head did you eat did it
it's still in the fire for me i don't
think
maybe you only ate one cheek wrong all
right so where's the next cave at nerds
okay so ready to murder if we go
basically across the river and keep
going straight
it's in the big village
that is down there but we could go to
bed first if you guys would prefer oh we
could sleep yeah
yeah we could definitely sleep we should
probably say go ahead and save the game
right now yeah we should go ahead and
save the game
i want to go and save the game right now
[Music]
all right welcome
really glad i ate all that food to be
hungry again to start the day okay we
got lots of food
food's not a problem here keep equipping
the food and not eating it which is very
strange
our berries are still never growing
berries i
picked them i was able to harvest them
never mind i guess i just
never got berries if you walk to the
middle of this patch that i'm in you
should be able to get like a whole thing
fine i don't have a berry bag you're
just not a
dumb idiot okay my fearless leader mark
which way is the thing
we go across the bridge and then we just
keep going until we get to the big
village it's in the big village which
bridge
the good bridge or our little bridge
either bridge where's my little bridge
oh my god oh my gosh
little bridge little bridge died
that's fine it's fine
oh there's a raft hey you guys remember
there's a raft yeah
yeah and how super beautiful that is
yeah why is it still
night didn't we go to bed we slept the
day away man
oh my god the katana harvest sticks so
efficiently dudes
oh yeah oh okay well we hit a snag on
the cliff face here
i think i went the wrong way to get up
at this is the same close face we spent
hours at before
oh my god left was not the correct way
to go to get up the cliff
oh no he didn't oh god what's this idiot
in charge
i don't know i'm trying to oh my god i
gotta go a
okay hey look we're up on the cliff now
so there should be a village here if it
was daytime we'd be able to see it
oh here poison berries i don't have a
bag so i can't
i can't collect but right here want to
take i
see a berry collection here but i can't
actually see the berries i don't know
what kind these are
these good or bad boys that's their eat
guys i ate them maybe chop it down maybe
that would collect it
good call ah is this good or bad are
these good or bad berries
white is bad white is bad i don't i just
don't see
berries it says eat eat i don't see
they're very clear
wait i need one more to make a point
there's another bush by me there's
another bush by me
oh i didn't collect them oh i don't know
there's all kinds of bad berries
yeah i can't collect them because i
don't have a bag but yeah feel free to
harvest now we've got
bad berries okay i can't collect them
either i can only eat them or trap them
down
well that doesn't make any sense oh mark
there's remnants of a village here
yeah where is this i wish i could see i
wish i could see
okay this is a village if only it wasn't
nighttime somewhere in here
there's an entrance specific
aha here got it found it
i haven't found it yet mark okay i'm
restocking on my cloth though that's
good ah
i broke your chairs um there's a person
over here
stuffed with tennis balls yeah i found
this before
there's a guy over here who's absolutely
been sacrificed we should go in the hole
they're coming
[Music]
you